what up guys do you want to hang out and
train with me because for the month of
april every single order or eml sign up
enters you into a chance to train with
me at the barbell brigade gym in la and
you can enter as many times as you want
to increase your chances there'll be
three winners that'll be randomly picked
and announced on instagram we'll be
covering all the travel expenses that
means flight hotel food and you'll be
featured on the bartle brigade youtube
channel while we train
so see you guys peace
[Music]
[Music]
what's up guys super excited for today
because i get to do a little bit of play
and i always love a little bit of play
and my kind of play
is more centered around like beauty
and specifically a try on haul i haven't
done one of these in such a long time i
have one of my girl girlfriend's
birthdays coming up she's from florida
but she's flying out to la with a bunch
of you know our other friends and it's
just gonna be like a girls get together
um
and we're gonna celebrate her her dirty
thirty
um we're gonna do it up some of them are
moms some of them are not so we're all
just going to get together have a good
time um be like super posh or whatever
um so i bought a few outfits to see what
it is that i want to wear
um so should we just do it
yeah let's just do it
okay so you know me if you know me um i
don't like to do a lot of shopping so i
like to find online shops because it has
to be online i can't do one person i
hate
i hate the whole experience in person so
i only find online shops that house a
lot of different labels in one place
um and you already know my go-to if it's
not urban outfitters
then it's um either like a nordstrom
which is super rare because they're kind
of pricey or it's asos and asos has like
a pretty good range from like
uh inexpensive to moderately expensive
not too expensive type stuff um so
all that i'm going to try on today is
specifically from asos this is not
sponsored but if you work for aso's
corporate side and you want to sponsor
me
i'm not mad because
i've bought a lot from eso's a lot but
yeah not sponsored gonna give you my
honest feedback um
okay now let's get started i did say
that the first one but now let's get
started okay okay
okay so the first look
is the dress i've been already talking
in
um i'm trying to go for like a classy
like nice restaurant day vibe type of
look
that you can kind of dress up for like a
like a dinner
um i really like this topo it looks like
it's topographic honestly but it just i
don't know i feel like it's such an in
print
i honestly don't know what's in or
what's not in i just kind of go based
off of what i like and what i see other
people wearing and i go okay i either
have seen it too much
and i'm not attracted to it or i've seen
it too much and i love it so i do get it
but i don't really follow up with much
of the stuff that's happening right now
we have tyke over here watching and
eating lunch
okay so this is the first look
ignore
i'm gonna try to show you the shoes
without showing you too much more
because my feet look busted like so
busted
but i'll get them fixed so
sorry
they're really busted okay anyway okay
so i got both of these shoes
so one's more of like a classic
like
like i'm older
type of look it's not strappy
it's just like a smaller mid heel i
guess
so it looks like that
cute right but this one just gives me a
younger hipper vibe
it is a little bit of a higher heel
and i think it would look better
with this shoe
i also like
the tightness of the dress and because i
think of all the little flowy design
it hides a lot of
imperfections if you will it is
see-through-ish
but
not enough like you can't tell that i'm
wearing
i'm kind of i'm wearing like beige
underwear but
yes i'm keeping this honey
[Music]
cute
honey
okay next look
cute i think i'll probably wear it with
these shoes too
very cute
okay so if you like this dress it's on
asos i just bought it it's by fashion
killa and i got it in a size oh i don't
know some of the sizes run european
okay well this was made in the uk
um but i'm a medium so whatever that
translates to i'm a medium and i'm five
eleven so if you're interested in the
dress i think it's very flattering
um i think it works on all body types so
let's go
okay so this next look when i put it on
my face was like
it's good okay so here we go this is the
next one i'm trying it on with two
different
shoes i bought some really high boots
and then obviously the ones that i was
just wearing i felt like it worked with
both but let's look at this
so it's
again busy pattern which i feel like
again just kind of accentuates
the right stuff and hides the wrong
stuff you know what i mean
look at the back though
she didn't come to play
not sure i'm liking this look let me see
if i can do like a half mirror look
so it'd be like that
they're too high up i think the slit
is really cute really sexy kind of rides
up a little bit i'll probably put on
like some fashion tape has a little
peekaboo
here on the side
probably won't pair it with these boots
but i feel like with these shoes it
looks really pretty
look at that whoops
right
yeah i'm not sure if this will be the
final shoe i wear it with i'm just
showing you what i bought it or what i
bought and just trying to pair it
i specifically just bought for this trip
um and i'm really trying really hard
not to like anything so that it can
return
because i don't want to keep all this
[ __ ] like i don't go out you guys see me
we're always home or i'm always working
and like i don't go out enough so um
that's why i was looking for super
inexpensive things that can work day and
night
um so maybe that's a pro for you guys if
you don't
go out as much and you don't have a big
budget or you just don't want to spend
uh that much then i would look for
things that you can dress up and dress
down
um and then things that are timeless so
these aren't the most timeless like this
one i wouldn't say is pretty timeless
but i feel like it's gonna work for a
long time i would say this one's pretty
timeless and it's super sexy right
so
you can kind of do that
girl
i love it it
does the body good
i love it
keeping it for sure
okay so if you like this dress this is
actually just an asos
design dress so i would probably
have a dress too you do let me see your
dress wow
so pretty i like it
i love it it's a blanket but i'm getting
a blanket dress
cute
okay so this is the next dress
this one i it feels like i can't really
dress it down i mean up
maybe i can
who knows
um i'm still i feel like these still are
the cutest shoes i tried on the gold
ones it didn't work um i got these other
clear ones that have like a
or not leica but they have a bow on them
what i don't know
oh careful okay
yeah i don't know if i like it i don't
even know if i like this dress i feel
like i have too many kind of casualty
dresses it doesn't fit the best
okay so decisions have been made this is
a very
very beautiful dress i don't like
how the straps feel it feels like my
boobs are going to pop out i feel like
they're a little too long
and i was thinking well maybe i can
slice down
i'm talking a little bit slower because
or lower because tech is about to take a
nap
um
but sizing down is not possible because
this already feels so tight
so i think i'm gonna take this one back
because i don't even need it
oh my god sorry i forgot but if you like
it it's by asos
design and i found my
there it is
asos design strappy midi dress
color multi and it's a uk 12 which is a
medium
in the us
um and it might be like an 8
or 10
in u.s sizing i don't know why we have
so many sizes but yeah if you like it i
think it's a beautiful dress i really do
think it's beautiful there's the straps
are just not my vibe and yeah i mean i
just i'm not gonna wear it anywhere so
i think it accentuates the right places
and hides the wrong places
um it's lengthy i wouldn't recommend it
on someone that's a little bit shorter
just because it is really long you guys
saw 511 and it was like
um
a few inches above my ankle so
i would
advise
to kind of be weary of that because if
you're shorter
it's just going to look like a gown so
yeah hope i hope if you like it i hope
uh
it works for you
okay so this is the next look
not really filling it i'll show you why
okay
so this one's really beautiful
before night time it has like this like
silky
type of feel to it
i'm not sure it's not really flattering
here
i am wider in the hips just because of
that i think this
gives you more hips cause everything
bunches up am i wearing it crooked i
don't even know what's happening right
now
yeah not a fan it makes me look super
hippy because of this extra
all the extra fabric it's a very
beautiful dress
but i don't think it suits me very well
anyway i paired it with the gold shoes
you guys have seen and these are so many
ones i haven't showed you these are
with the plastic let's see
i don't know how i feel about these i
feel like my feet are just gonna
accumulate a bunch of sweat and you're
gonna see it at the tip
i don't know but they're so pretty
look at that
it doesn't quite go with this look
but it's okay
because i don't like the dress
right oops sorry i just don't think i'm
the right
body type for it but it's a gorgeous
dress
it really is beautiful
it's just not for me
yeah
because i think if you're someone that
wants
more hips i think it'll cinch really
nicely for you because my waist got a
little bit bigger because of having uh
taika
but if you want more of a waste this is
the way to go
and this is cute with a nice little
push-up bra
but yeah it's not for me it's a pass
okay so
that dress didn't work out for me but if
you think it's gonna work out for you it
is
aso's
design
still a beautiful dress i did silk when
i meant satin
so there you go
okay so i have the next look on and it's
a little clevage heavy for me let me
show you
so it's another satin dress
i'd like that this one now has like this
v line
or v taper which gives the illusion of a
cinched in noise even though it does
have this extra fabric so it gives the
illusion that my waist is smaller and my
hips
aren't doing the most even though i'm
really happy and you can see it kind of
bunch up here
not cute
and it's very
clavage focused
after having kids your clavash gets very
sad and droopy
hence mine
you should be like boom [ __ ]
boom [ __ ] but nope they're down here
they're really sad
this is the back
it's really pretty
like a long
longer tail in the back
slit in the front i don't like that i
can see that
the seam there not very cute i paired it
up with these two shoes
it kind of works
let's see
like that or
like that i've been purposely wearing
these to see
how sweaty they'll get and not too bad i
mean they are a little bit
a little bit steamy in there but not as
bad as i would think so try to keep them
on and see if i want to keep them okay
with that being said
i'm gonna pass this ain't my vibe
like
no dude
not my vibe at all
okay so not for me but if it's for you
here it is
it's asos let's see corset satin midi
dress in brown
see you later hope you make someone else
happy
pro tip open the bags carefully don't
rip them just in case you have to return
it um and as soon as you take it off
pack it right away so you can see here
i've already started putting my returns
back in the box so i don't have to think
about it later it is you'll thank me
later trust me you'll thank me later
okay let's do the next look
okay so this is the next look
and it's
definitely
[Music]
not my vibe so this is what i'm talking
about when i'm when i'm saying um
the print
highlights the good hides the bad this
is one that doesn't have a print that's
not highlighting any of my good
my perceived good okay
so
this already is just not my vibe
um but look you see i have the hip dents
not that there's anything wrong with it
i just don't like it and because the
material is a little bit thicker it
shows
poofs as a little bit bigger than what
they really are but
anyway
um yeah not my vibe
not my vibe at all
the model that was wearing it looks so
perfect in it and i was like oh i could
see myself in it but
i just don't have that body type so the
same for me
okay so this dress wasn't for me but if
it's for you
here you go
it's asos design
again it's a us8 uk12
here are the details
hope it works out for you
okay
this is the next look
it's not for going out at all it's just
looking cute with my girlfriends
not really my vibe because i'm tall
and it's a halter really cool design
actually is you don't tie it you just
put it around
your neck so there's no guessing
involved because god damn some of the
girl clothes i'm guessing like what
strap goes where what the hell am i
supposed to do with this um but because
i'm tall it is giving me mad camel toe
so no it gives me like a stelena
selena's
a selena vibe a little bit
because it flares out at the bottom
so yeah no we're not doing it
it's the back
you don't give me a wedgie
you definitely give me hamilton what the
[ __ ]
not for me dude
okay so this romper wasn't for me but if
it's for you
this is who makes it this is the details
okay so these are the next items i
bought
not meant to be paired together i just
meant to buy them to pay them with other
stuff in my closet
so these are some
slack
high-waisted pants but
they're i guess they're supposed to be
high-waisted but they're a little too
loose they resemble pajama pants a
little too much the color is beautiful
but i just don't like the way it fits
it does have pockets which is really
really nice but here
if it was like a little bit
tighter or i don't know something's off
with them that i'm not a big fan of
this top is just
a cute little
it has like a wire in here to keep to
give it that v shape i don't know
i might not keep it i don't see what the
what the appeal is
but for the rest of the items that i did
buy which are bottoms i'll keep them on
but yeah i'm not a fan
also shoe check i've been wearing them
they just stay a little steamy but
whoops
that's about it they're super
comfortable
looks like i might keep them
yeah but returning these
i don't know about this
i've told myself if it's not a [ __ ] yes
it's a [ __ ] no so the fact that i'm
going i don't know that means i need to
return both but for now for the sake of
the try on i'll keep this one on
okay wait
i think i'm gonna keep the pants so i
just put this shirt on
super cute corset style
shirt and as soon as i put it on it
changed the whole fit
so i think i'm gonna keep them
what the [ __ ] how did that happen
it's all the illusions
okay well i guess what's going to
determine it is the price
if the price is like under 40 bucks then
i'll keep it if it's above 40 bucks nah
not worth it
i can't think i'm gonna keep it that's
really cute
moving just this
i don't know i don't know
it's either [ __ ] yes or [ __ ] no i gotta
remember that
but the color is so nice
okay so if you liked
this top
you know the v
is by
three people in a large maybe i should
have gone medium i thought my boobs
would be bigger
but they're not yeah i don't know
it wasn't really my thing but if it's
yours there you go okay final decision
these were not for me but if they're for
you
here you go
i think also if you're not 511 like me
they'll fit you a lot longer because
when i wasn't wearing high heels they
just they were super high water and not
in a cute way either so these might be
for you
so this is the next one you guys already
saw the top
which keeps falling and i don't like
that so i might not keep this
and it is see-through i am wearing this
part of see-through so i am wearing
something underneath just be advised
okay i've been wanting leather pants for
a long time but just
nope
just haven't found the wand
it's a big here i don't know it's just
not for me
look at that i look frumpy
nope
not for me
returning them
okay so that top and that bottom
not for me but if it's for you
there you go
that's the top
okay so this isn't meant to be together
and i don't like the way it looks let me
show you so
these are from topshop these are the
same ones as the black ones i didn't
know when i bought it at the time i
thought they would look cute i just look
like a sausage in its casing
not very flattering i do have like this
like insulation on the inside
which makes it
super warm and very comfortable actually
but i just
it's not cute
i don't like them
i love the color just not the fitment
not for me and then this top like what
the [ __ ]
has no support ties in the front my
boobies are falling out of the bottom
in my head it fit better
but i think it's because the model isn't
511 she doesn't have a long ass torso
like me
so it looks really cute
some tops just don't look good with
girls with big boobs
i think this is
this is for the geo before implants type
body
this would look really cute but yeah i'm
gonna pass on both
this is like the satin too it's really
pretty
just not for me
okay so if you like the pants
here you go
okay
not meant to be paired together i was
hoping the pants would be a little bit
looser they're a little too tight a
little too short
for me
and my hips are a little too wide for it
so it makes the pots pockets just pop
out this top is cute though
this is something you can dress
dress up for sure
so i'm gonna keep the top
the bottom is not so much
top
yes i don't know if it's supposed to fit
the short i'm so tall i feel like
nothing ever fits me the right way
okay so i decided not to keep the pink
shirt i kept wearing it and it was so
uncomfortable it's cutting off my
circulation
i think my lats are too big
from lifting
and i like that i like that a lot
okay anyway but if you like that shirt
here are the details
and then here are the details for the
pants
yes
okay so i [ __ ] up ordered this top my
tits are about to fall out of it
i'm getting choked
here because there's just not enough
fabric to cover my boobies
but it's supposed to
like it's like a corset
yeah hold on let me fix this because
this is just getting nuts
[Music]
okay so i had to lift it up this is not
the way it goes obviously i'm not gonna
keep it cause it doesn't fit okay
sequins pants
is a [ __ ] vibe i think i'm gonna keep
these
well i gotta see how much they cost
because i don't like the way they fit me
i mean they're not like the best but
they're not the worst either
but [ __ ]
how fun
let's see
i'll let you know
okay i had to remind myself if it's not
a [ __ ] yes at the [ __ ] no so i had to
get rid of those sequins pants
so if the shirt is something cute
for you there you go
and then the pants
if they were just bigger or just i was
smaller i don't know i got a large too
jesus
yeah they just didn't fit they didn't
work for me but they're so cute
okay so i'm done trying stuff on my hair
it's short i was holding it up but with
putting things on and off
um it just fell out i was trying to do
like little french braid situations when
it dries it's all like crinkly and cute
didn't happen but i also wanted to share
um some accessories that i did get
um and what i ended up keeping so let's
talk about the accessories first
i got these little earrings whoa kind of
out of focus let me see
here we go
they look like that so you wear them
this way
and if you like them
that's what they're called
i really like that um asos does this as
soon as you open the bag they won't let
you return it anymore
um here
they're not cool so since i opened it
it's mine
and then these guys because it looks
like they're like super stocked and
double layered
if you like them
there you go
i have an anklet because why not
then that's what it is
then i thought this was really cool
it's really short too
i want to say it's like maybe
12
so it's pretty tight to the collarbone
so i ended up keeping the two dresses
did i tried one
and then i kept these shoes here
and i think these are like 50 bucks and
i think these are 40 bucks everything
else that you guys saw i returned it
and everything's ready
set to
i go it
yeah
and tyka actually fell asleep
he's watching the new spiderman
okay well i can't wait to dress it up
and go out and try these things out in
public it's so cute
just have to make sure i get
the right stuff
in terms of shoes because the shoes that
go good with both of those i'm actually
returning because
besides wearing them for this time i
don't know when else i would wear them
whereas these
you can always use gold shoes
and these are just way so cute
they're just so [ __ ] cute i have to
do it
i'm a big sparkle person so the fact
that there's a sparkle
i'm all about it so
i think i have basics i'll see what i
can pair it with and then i'll start
digging through my closet to see what
outfits i should wear and bring with me
because i'm going to be there
friday night
um
friday saturday come back sunday
afternoon and it's in la so it's like
literally a 45 minute um airplane ride
so about they'll take me about
two hours of trouble maybe
maybe pushing it so yeah super stoked
okay i'm gonna stop making noise because
i want this dude to sleep so you can
feel better okay bye
thank you so much for watching okay